[Musique]
Jean-Marc Jancovici bonjour vous êtes
associé de Carbon 4 président de the
shift project et vous avez publié fin
2015 dormez tranquille jusqu'en 200 et
autres malentendu sur le climat et
l'énergie aux édition ODIL Jacob alors
dans ce livre vous revenez sur un
certain nombre d'événements liés au
pétrole même si cela ne pas pas évident
de prime à bord il y a un chapitre
notamment où vous liez pétrole et monté
du Front national en France est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer le
mécanisme alors le mécanisme en fait il
dépasse la France et il s'explique de la
manière suivante quand on a démarré la
civilisation industrielle on est passé
de la force des bras et des jambes à la
force des machines et ce qui alémente
les machines c'est de l'énergie dont
notamment le pétrole qui commande toutes
les machines à se déplacer donc soit
nous-mêmes soit des marchandises et en
fait on peut assez facilement montrer
que dans le monde la variation du PIB
reflète très exactement la variation de
la production de pétrole h quand vous
avez un peu moins de pétrole sans
l'avoir souhaité ce qui est le cas en
Europe depuis 2006 hein depuis 2006
l'Europe est en décru pétrolières subie
c'estàd qu'il y a plus assez de pétrole
dans le monde pour que la consommation
augmente en Europe vous vous retrouvez
avec deux problèmes conjoints d'une part
le PIB arrête de monter voire descend
qu'on constate dans tous les pays
européens à des degrés d'hivers sauf
l'Allemagne mais euh depuis 2007 et à ce
moment l'économie souffre et quand
l'économie souffre elle commence par
réjecter du système les gens dont elle a
le moins besoin et les gens dont elle a
le moins besoin sont ceux qui sont les
moins qualifiés où est-ce qu'ils
habitent ces braves gens ils habitent en
général en périphérie lointaine des
villes parce que c'est là que le foncier
est le moins cher mais pour autant ces
gens restent dans le bassin d'attraction
économique des villes c'est pas des
agriculteurs c'est pas des gens qui font
du bûcheronnage c'est des gens qui ont
un emploi de bureau ou un emploi dans un
magasin mais ils habitent un peu loin de
la ville et si l'économie souffre parce
qu'il n'y a pas assez de pétrole par
ailleurs ces gens-là ont de plus en plus
de mal à se se déplacer parce qu'ils
vivent dans des espaces suffisamment peu
dens pour que il y ait pas une offre de
transport public très abondante et il
n'y en aura jamais parce que il y a pas
assez d'habitants au kilomètres carrés
pour rentabiliser des transports en
commun donc ces gens-là ont de moins en
moins de travail accessible ont des
charges pour se déplacer ou une facilité
à se déplacer qui va en diminuant donc
ils ont vraiment l'impression d'être
abandonnés et à ce moment ils se mettent
à voter avec leurs pieds c'est-à-dire à
voter pour les populistes et en France
depuis 25 ans à peu près quel que soit
la nature de l'élection on constate que
le vote pour le Front National est
maximal à 40 km du centre des grandes
villes et cette règle elle est
universelle moins de pétrole c'est plus
d'extrémisme politique oui on constate
partout en Europe alors il y avait un
petit billet dans les échos il y a un an
à peu près qui expliquait que c'était
noir au nord et rouge au sud
c'est-à-dire c'était plutôt l'extrême
droite qui était en vogue au nord et
plutôt l'extrême gauche qui était en
vogue au sud mais on voit les mouvements
populistes monter partout en Europe
exactement pour les mêmes raisons parce
que la décru pétrolière subie touche
toute l'Europe du coup la décru
industrielle touche toute l'Europe à
l'exception de l'Allemagne pour le
moment mais quand les émergents vont
ralentir pour de bon elle sera concernée
aussi et du reste on voit aussi en
Allemagne les populistes commencer à
gagner du terrain plus tard que les
autres mais ils en gagnent également et
on peut même associer le brexit à ce
mouvement d'ensemble parce que qu'est-ce
que c'est que le populisme c'est le
replis sur soi hein c'est je sors de
l'euro je sors de l'Europe je sais et
cetera donc Marine Le Pen veut sortir de
l'Europe Boris Johnson veut aussi sortir
de l'Europe voilà ils sont sur la la
seule différence c'est qu'il va avoir un
référendum organisé en Grande-Bretagne
mais sinon dans le discours c'est
exactement pareil est-ce qu'il faut en
déduire que le concept même de
démocratie arrive à ses limites puisque
le concept de démocratie est né et s'est
développé dans un monde de croissance il
est très intéressant de noter je l'ai
découvert en écrivant ce livre que au
moment où la Grande-Bretagne a basculé
dans la démocratie Grande-Bretagne qui a
été le premier grand pays à le faire ça
faisait de siècles que son taux de
croissance par personne était plus élevé
que partout ailleurs dans le monde et la
démocratie c'est quoi c'est un maximum
de liberté individuelle il est très
facile de laisser à chacun un maximum de
liberté quand on est dans un univers en
expansion parce que ce que vous allez
utiliser vous comme espace de liberté ne
gêne pas l'espace de liberté du voisin
dans un univers en expansion dans un
univers en contraction c'est beaucoup
plus difficile il faut partager la
contrainte imaginer un bateau dans le
gros temps commencer par faire une
élection avant chaque décision que doit
prendre le capitaine on comprend que
c'est un peu compliqué et que c'est un
peu plus logique même si c'est un peu
plus cruel
que on a décidé qu'il était le seul
maître à bord après Dieu et qui faisait
exactement ce qu'il voulait parce qu'il
pensait que c'était bon pour la marche
du bateau j'ai bien peur malheureusement
qu'il en soit exactement de même pour
les pays dit industriel en période de
contraction énergétique c'est-à-dire que
la contrainte va rendre de plus en plus
difficile si on y prend garde le
maintien de la démocratie comment est-ce
que vous expliquez que ce lien entre
croissance et pétrole ne soit pas
davantage dans les médias dans les
discours politiques c'est l'un des
grands intérêts de votre livre c'est que
la démonstration elle est limpide elle
est clair on est immédiatement
convaincu ça fait un certain temps
maintenant que l'économie ne s'intéresse
plus aux sous-jacent physique euh de de
l'économie justement elle-même donc en
gros la majeure partie des économistes
il raisonnent dans une espèce de monde
en à pesanteur comme si le PIB était
procédait de la génération spontanée
vous savez comme les êtres vivants il y
a quelques siècles donc il apparaît on
sait pas trop pourquoi euh et après ce
qui est intéressant c'est de savoir ce
qu'on en fait alors non évidemment le pb
il a besoin de sous-jacent physique
c'est bien parce qu'on a des fibres
textiles à transformer que vous avez les
vêtements que vous avez sur vous et que
j'ai les vêtements que j'ai sur moi et
s'il y a pas de fibre textile et ben il
y a pas de production de textile donc
pour faire du PIB il faut produire et
pour produire il faut des ressources à
transformer donc on oublie trop souvent
qu'il y a ça alors pourquoi est-ce que
les économistes ne s'y intéressent pas
il y a plusieurs explications possibles
la première c'est que c'est désagréable
de coller des limites physique dans un
système quand pendant très longtemps on
a manipulé un système sans limite parce
que la théorie économique classique elle
a pas de limite donc pourquoi
voulez-vous mettre des limites c'est
désagréable une deuxième explication
possible c'est que ça fait une vingtaine
d'années m'a dit un économiste que ce
secteur là ne s'intéresse pas à la
fonction de production donc si vous vous
intéressez pas à la fonction de
production mais juste sa pourquoi
l'efficience des marchés un autre truc
comme ça et bien vous ne voyez pas ce
qu'il y a derrière la production donc
vous ne voyez pas la physique
sous-jacente à la production enfin je il
faudrait aller demander et creuser en
profondeur la seule chose que je sais
par contre et ça c'est un de vos
confrères des écho qui m'avait expliqué
ça c'est que si on accepte l'idée qui
pour moi me paraît évidente qu'il y a de
la physique derrière l'économie à ce
moment ça oblige les économistes
classiques à jeter bas l'essentiel de
100 ou 150 ans d'héritage intellectuel
accumulé donc il repartent à peu près
nuus et évidemment c'est une pensée qui
est très désagréable pour les gens qui
en font parti donc on continue à
fonctionner avec des règles qui sont
fausses mais qui sont accepté par les
gens qui ont intérêt et ça sera
évidemment les derniers à avoir envie de
s'en séparer et bien merci beaucoup
Jean-Marc jeancovici en tout cas voilà
qui fait réfléchir on ne peut pas
promettre la croissance aux électeurs
merci
[Musique]
encore